- [Instructor] Let's do
some example questions
dealing with ratios.
So we're told, "The table shows
the number of people waiting
"in line for different
rides at an amusement park."
So 15 people are waiting in
line for the roller coaster,
four people for the slingshot,
12 people waiting in line
for the bumper cards,
and 11 people in line for the round-up.
"What is the ratio of
people waiting in line
"for the round-up
"to the people waiting in
line for the slingshot?"
Pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
So we wanna know the ratio
of the people waiting in line
for the round-up, this is
the round-up right over here,
to the number of people waiting
in line for the slingshot.
So, there's 11 people waiting
in line for the round-up,
and there are four people waiting
in line for the slingshot,
so the ratio is 11 to four.
Or for every 11 people
in line for the round-up,
there are four people waiting
in line for the slingshot.
Let's do another example.
"Katie loves to read!
"In the last few months, she
has read three graphic novels,
"two mysteries, four
science fiction novels,
"and 21 comic books.
"What is the ratio of sci-fi
novels to comic books?"
So once again, pause this video
and try to work it out on your own.
All right, so we wanted to know
the ratio of sci-fi novels,
so she has four sci-fi novels,
the ratio of that to comic books.
She has 21 comic books.
So the ratio is for
every four sci-fi novels,
she has 21 comic books.
Do you want me to do
that in that other color?
She has 21 comic books.
So the ratio is four to 21,
the ratio of sci-fi novels to comic books.
Four sci-fi novels for
every 21 comic books.
Let's do one more example.
This is strangely fun.
"What is the ratio of apples to bananas?"
Pause this video and try to figure it out.
So let's see, there are
one, two, three apples.
So for every three apples,
how many bananas are there?
Well, there's one, two,
three, four bananas.
So the ratio of apples to,
the ratio of apples to
bananas is three apples
for every four bananas.
Order matters.
If they said the ratio
of bananas to apples,
then this would be four to three,
but they say apples to
bananas, three to four.
Three apples for every four bananas.